a plus b times open parenthesis c plus d
is equal to a
plus b c plus b d
represents which of the following
properties so to get from the left hand
side to the right hand side it looks
like what they did is they multiplied
the b times the c plus d in fact they
distributed the b
b times c plus d is b times c
plus b times d so this is clearly the
distributive property
let's do another one
four plus open parenthesis ten plus six
they're saying is the same thing as four
plus ten first plus six so on the left
hand side we're doing the ten plus six
first and then we're adding the four on
the right hand side we're adding the
four plus ten first and then we're
adding the six and we're saying it's
they're equal to each other it doesn't
matter how we associate these numbers
here we're associating the 10 and the
six first and then we're adding the four
here we're associating the four and the
ten first and then we're adding the six
so this is the associative property for
addition
associative
let's do several more
a plus b is equal to b plus a represents
which of the following properties so it
doesn't matter which order i'm adding
doesn't matter if i do a plus b or b
plus a this is the commutative property
do another one
which one of the equations on the right
represents the associative property of
addition so remember associative
property we're talking about it doesn't
matter how we associate the numbers so
if we might do the operation on two of
the numbers first and then on the third
or on or or on maybe two of the other
numbers and then on the the one that's
left over so let's see what over here
looks like that so this right over here
this is the commutative property this
right over here is the distributive
property this one right over here on the
left on the left hand side we had b plus
c first on the right hand side we add a
plus b first and these two things are
equal to each other doesn't matter how
we associated if we associate b c first
or a plus b first so this is the
associative property of addition
let's do which of the following which of
which one of the equations on the right
represents the distributive property of
addition over multiplication
so let's see where this first one
they're just changing the associations
here this is commutative this last one
here they're actually distributing the b
over the c plus d so b times c plus d is
the same thing as bc plus bd
so it's that one right over there
maybe do a few more of this this is a
lot of fun
a plus b plus c is equal to a plus b
plus c so this once again they are
reassociating the numbers but it doesn't
matter which order we associate them in
so this is the associative this is the
associative property
which one of the equations on the right
represents the commutative property of
addition so commutative we don't care
about the order in which we're doing the
operation so a plus b is equal to b plus
a
which one of the equations the right
represents the commutative property of
addition well that's what they just
asked us a plus b is equal to b plus a
and we are done